[Musik]
diese Woche geht im Linzer Design Center
die diesjährige IKT Konferenz über die
Bühne Hauptthema dieses Jahr einmal mehr
beim größten Branchentreffen dieser Art
it Sicherheit bleibt unangeefochten
Thema Nummer 1 ich glaube Sicherheit im
itbereich ist ein Thema wo wir uns alle
damit beschäftigen müssen weil ja
Digitalisierung und IT unseren gesamten
Lebensbereich inzwischen durchtringt
hier Bewusstsein zu schaffen welche
Möglichkeiten es gibt aber auch welche
Risken sich daraus eben ist glaube ich
ein ein zentraler Punkt den diese
Konferenz ansprechen möchte
Cyberattacken gehören mittelweile zum
Tagesgeschäft eines jeden it-exerten
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Tanner
erinnert daran dass diese Angriffe
stetig mehr werden tagtäglich werden
weltweit Vorfälle gemeldet und auch der
Krieg in der Ukraine ist ein Beispiel
dafür wie Cyberangriffe durchaus
Bestandteil auch der Kriegsführung
geworden sind und nicht zuletzt deshalb
ist es unabdingbar notwendig dass wir
den cyberbereich
entwickeln weiterentwickeln das ist für
uns in Österreich unabdingbar notwendig
also wenn man jetzt da alleine sich
anseht was das österreische bundesjah in
den letzten Monaten für Anstrengungen
unternommen hat um nachzurüsten ist es
also vor allem im Vergleich zu anderen
oder auch zu Nachbarländern beachtlich
ich wir haben da die richtigen
Entscheidungen getroffen und wir
versuchen da jetzt schnell Tempo
aufzuholen um dann den Soldaten das zu
geben sie brauchen und tatsächlich auch
eine Chance am gefechtsf zu haben und
ich denke man kann da absolut positive
Dinge sein ja was allerdings im immer
größeren Ausmaß feht sind junge
nachwuchsspezialisten und
Spezialistinnen also wir haben mit der
Challenge die wir von Anfang an
unterstützt haben und immer
mitorganisieren da war die Idee was
gibt's denn für Talente in Österreich
und wie Kön man das auch zur Bund holen
was in Einzelfällen tatsächlich gelingt
und ich glaube alle anderen sind heiß
begehrt und ich glaube für alle
interessant wie viele junge Leute wir
hier haben mit einer fundierten
Ausbildung in cybersicherheit haben
junge Menschen heute die allerbesten
Berufschancen die Jobangebote werden
ständig mehr und die
Verdienstmöglichkeiten sind enorm das
ist in der Tat richtig also wer die Müh
der Ebenen überquert und tatsächlich es
in die Cyber Security Community schafft
also der hat wenn man so möchte also
finanziell keine Sorgen mehr also da
gibt wirklich tolle und lukrative
Angebote und man kann s auch wirklich
aussuchen trotzdem diese jungen Menschen
nicht von den Bäumen regnet liegt al
wirklich daran dass es sehr müsam ist
und sehr schwierig ist sich dieses
Knowhow und diese Kompetenzen anzueignen
und Exzellenz in diesen fechern zu
entwickeln dafür bedarf es wirklich
mehrere Jahre und trennt sie schlicht
einfach SPR Weizen wie weit man es
wirklich bringen kann wenn man sein
Handwerk richtig versteht be der
österreichische Nobelpreisträger für
Physik Zeilinger er se Vortrag nicht mit
der einen oder anderen heiteren Anekdote
was ist die Beziehung und Wirklichkeit
Information die Frage ist habe ich das
da ja ist der Mond da wenn keiner
hinschaut sag man Spinner die Frag und
da gab's eine Diskussion zwischen Albert
Einstein und Nils boh Albert Einstein
fragte Nils boh glauben Sie wirklich
dass der Mond nicht da ist und keiner
hinsieht worauf im Nils boh gesagt hat
beweisen sie mir doch das
Gegenteil